bom boa tarde a todos
é eu falo do lugar de uma professora do
departamento de música do instituto de
artes da unicamp que trabalha atualmente
com formação de professores de música
com o foco em olhar pra escola na escola
de educação básica brasileira
dentro dessa perspectiva
nós temos no brasil entre as décadas de
30 e 60
algumas oportunidades né de trabalho com
música dentro de escolas
a iniciativa de villa lobos com o cantor
piô nico onde as pessoas cantavam
efetivamente aprendiam teoria musical
aprendeu a surfar e já aprendi um hinos
na entre as décadas de 1930 e 1960
posteriormente a isso na década de 60 ou
uma transa um período de transição no
nosso país ea partir da década de 70 foi
implementado o ensino de educação
artística nas escolas né com uma
perspectiva mais polivalente onde era
exigido do profissional que iria
ministrar as aulas nas escolas que ele
desce conta das linguagens de diversas
linguagens artísticas e o que se
observou
nesse tempo né é posterior à década de
70 foi o esvaziamento da música nas
escolas não a ausência coisa música
estava nas escolas ela podia estar nas
escolas ela estava garantida dentro do
ensino de educação artística
mas o que se observou na prática foi o
esvaziamento no ensino de outras
possibilidades diferentes do desenho e
de atividades mais focadas nas artes
visuais com a nova lei de diretrizes e
bases da educação que foi implementado
em 1996 no nosso país
tivemos novamente a possibilidade de
resgatar quatro linguagens artísticas né
agora música a dança o teatro e as artes
visuais e houve uma grande discussão dos
profissionais envolvidos com
essas áreas para que elas fossem
efetivamente implementadas nas escolas
brasileiras
a música então os profissionais
envolvidos com a música é nós que
entendemos nós músicos educadores
musicais profissionais que lidam com
música entendemos que a música faz parte
da vida do ser humano e portanto ela tem
a possibilidade de contribuir dentro da
da realidade escolar para a formação
integral do indivíduo nénão por uma
formação específica para pôr o indivíduo
ser músico através do que aprendi na
escola mas uma formação global uma
formação é que tem vai trazer uma
contribuição para esse indivíduo seja
ele criança seja ele adolescente adulto
enfim nós vivemos num mundo repleto de
sons repleto de música né e e isso nos
faz ser esculturalmente musicais
portanto entendemos que o esse
conhecimento musical pode e deve estar
na escola deve ser contemplado chegando
então agora na nos dias mais atuais né
2008 foi implementada a lei 11.769 em
agosto de 2008 que torna obrigatório o
ensino de música apesar de já está
contemplado dentro da lei de 1996 a lei
de diretrizes e bases
ele efetivamente continuava sem
acontecer assim como o ensino de teatro
e de dança
o ensino de arte na verdade era mais
focado nas artes visuais então portanto
os profissionais dessas quatro
linguagens artísticas começaram a
promover discussões e no caso da área de
música
isso culminou com a implementação dessa
lei que foi sancionada em agosto de 2008
as escolas brasileiras teriam há três
anos para implementar efetivamente o
ensino musical nas suas instalações
né porém o que nós observamos é que isso
efetivamente ainda não acontece tem
acontecido
mais freqüência existem inúmeras
iniciativas isoladas
existem iniciativas municipais estaduais
em fim o ensino musical está sendo
ampliado no país
porém a lei não está efetivamente
acontecendo na então isso proporcionou
que nós educadores musicais encabeçados
pela associação brasileira de educação
musical abem tivéssemos uma série de
encontros e discussões junto com a
câmara de educação básica que é um setor
do conselho nacional de educação não é
ligado ao mec e que fosse por ser
promovidos diversos encontros para que
se chegasse em algumas propostas para
efetivar realmente essa nova lei 11.079
então no dia 4 de dezembro de 2013
nós tivemos há um projeto de resolução
da câmera da câmara de educação básica
aprovados na i o meu foco aqui vai ser
falar brevemente desse projeto de
resolução porque ele aborda uma série de
questões que podem nos proporcionar
refletir sobre discussões são feitas
para implementação da música
então essa esse projeto de resolução que
ainda não é uma resolução que ainda não
foi homologado já foi aprovado mas ainda
tem que passar por algumas instâncias
para ser homologado ele foca em cinco
instâncias na na escola nas instituições
formadoras de educação superior
secretarias de educação conselhos de
educação e no ministério da educação
compete então as escolas a é necessário
que as escolas efetivamente incluam como
parte da sua programação que tem
relevância para a música como componente
curricular para que a música
efetivamente esteja presente né ela as
escolas precisam viabilizar a oferta
para todos os alunos porque é a música
tem feito parte dos currículos escolares
mas de uma forma extra
lá na verdade né como projetos então as
escolas precisam garantir que todos os
alunos realmente tenho acesso a essa
esse conhecimento da humanidade
aí para isso também é necessário que se
amplie a contratação de professores com
formação em música especificamente no
que diz respeito às instituições
formadoras de educação superior e também
de educação profissional a esses essas
instituições precisam ampliar o
oferecimento dos cursos de licenciatura
precisam oferecer para aqueles
profissionais que já têm uma formação em
uma das linguagens artísticas artes
visuais por exemplo que queiram
trabalhar com música que eles tenham
acesso a uma segunda licenciatura e
também que essa licenciatura tenha um
perfil voltado pra escola brasileira né
que o licenciando informação ele precisa
efetivamente têm um contato com a
realidade escolar
não adianta ele ele ser um excelente
músico mas não saber como vai lidar com
a realidade escolar brasileira dos
nossos dias ea secretaria de educação
não precisam ter realizar concursos
específicos esse é um dos problemas mais
graves para que nós tenhamos
efetivamente profissionais formados em
música trabalhando com música nas
escolas precisam promover a formação
continuada continuada de alguns
profissionais como professores que
trabalham com a educação infantil com as
séries iniciais do ensino fundamental
com o eja educação de jovens adultos
geralmente são os únicos professores
dessas pessoas crianças jovens adultos e
eles também podem eventualmente tocar um
instrumento já tem um certo domínio e
que se promova então uma formação
continuada para esses profissionais que
podem contribuir sim muito a
implementação do ensino musical nas
escolas é e que se viabilize também a
espaços adequados para que presta às
práticas musicais escolares não é
possível se ter aula de música num
espaço que não que faça muito barulho
para a sala ao lado ou que não tenha
nenhuma condições de se colocar um
instrumento é e
os equipamentos e essa manutenção de
todos os objetos extremamente necessário
para a aula de música
quanto aos conselhos de educação é
necessário então que eles definam normas
complementares às diretrizes nacionais a
que acompanhem os planos estaduais
distritais e municipais quanto à
avaliação da implementação das políticas
públicas
aí finalmente né o ministério da
educação compete ao ministério da
educação que deu o suporte à
implementação de todas essas políticas
dentro dessas instâncias que observe
nessas escolas se esses institutos
formadores do de profissionais que vão
atuar com o ensino musical estão
efetivamente dando conta de tudo que foi
proposto dentro das diretrizes e ainda
pra finalizar ela pela presença de
indicadores relativos ao ensino de
música ou seja a estão sendo
proporcionados exames a testes não é que
a que fiscalizem e que acompanhem o que
está sendo feito e como está sendo feito
o aproveitamento desses alunos dentro
das escolas
não é porque não adianta se a música
assim como a arte em geral ea educação
física se não forem disciplinas
valorizadas dentro da escola
se os alunos não fazem uma prova se os
alunos não têm no vestibular nem uma
questão dessas disciplinas as
disciplinas não são adequadamente e
valorizadas
então é só algumas algumas questões que
perpassam quando a gente pensa em termos
de implementar efetivamente o ensino
musical nas escolas brasileiras
muito obrigada uma boa tarde a todos